[Music]
huge b-52s flew up to 300 sorties a day
against suspected communist positions
[Music]
for nine years the united states
conducted one of the biggest bombing
campaigns in the history of the world
against the country pretty much no
american had any idea they were fighting
[Music]
the country they were targeting is not
one you've heard a lot about
it's not japan or korea or vietnam or
iraq
it's a country that is totally unknown
to the vast majority of people
this is the story of laos
on average bombs were dropped here every
eight minutes for nine years
randomly across fields and forests and
villages craters from the blasts still
scar the landscape about 80 million
undetonated bombs remain in the country
the american public needs to know what's
happening here that this is what their
country has has done and left behind
[Music]
laos is located right here in inland
southeast asia north of cambodia and
west of vietnam
historically of all these countries laos
was the poorest the least populated and
the least influential
since the end of the 19th century
vietnam cambodian laos had been french
possessions grouped together as french
indochina
but the decades after the second world
war saw a liberation struggle against
european colonialism
the year is 1954 the once mighty french
colonial empire in southeast asia is
doing
so along with cambodian vietnam laos
became an independent nation
but like its two sister countries laos
was split between royalists and
conservatives on the one hand and
communist rebels the potted lao on the
other
so along with the rest of indochina the
country entered a civil war
on its own the war would probably not
have been so bad the first years of the
conflict in fact were marked by relative
calm
but when larger and more important
vietnam descended into civil war in the
1960s and attracted international
involvement
laos became a proxy front in a much
bigger conflict
the united states
is therefore prepared to take all
necessary steps
in defense of freedom
the royalists governed a strip of land
in the west supported by american forces
based in thailand
the patatlao which ruled the north and
the east was propped up by its stronger
ally communist north vietnam
this had less to do with interest in
laos itself than with a question of
military logistics one of the biggest
targets of the vietnam era war was laos
some of the raids were aimed at
communist insurgents and others at the
ho chi minh trail the system of roads
that the enemy used to carry men and
supplies to the south
a big part of that trail ran through
eastern laos
as secretary of state dean rusk said
laos was only the wart on the hog
so the u.s planned a military campaign
to destroy the ho chi minh trail and
defeat the pathet law who are protecting
it they called it operation barrel roll
but there was something important
it would have to remain top secret no
mention of it was ever to be made to the
public not even to the united states
senate
it was called the secret war and was
operated not by the military but by the
cia
on the ground the us would supply a
warlord army composed of the country's
ethnic minorities
the war involved more than just nations
royalists and fiercely anti-communist
were often called the secret army
because they were supplied paid and
organized entirely by money and
officials from america's central
intelligence agency
the secret army was supplied by a
commercial airline called air america in
reality a cia front
the warlords used air america to smuggle
opium into vietnam in order to fund
their operations
and from above american planes would
attack at all hours of the day
washington never admitted the scale of
the bombing nor permitted film coverage
of it the only pictures released were
those showing rice supplies being
dropped to refugees
the scale of the bombing was enormous
[Music]
just look at this graphic created by
mother jones
[Music]
from 1964 to 1973 the united states
dropped more than 2 million tons of
bombs on laos
the u.s dropped more bombs just on laos
than it dropped during the entirety of
the second world war on both germany and
japan
a bomb was dropped an average of every
eight minutes 24 hours a day for nine
years
from bases in thailand huge b-52s flew
up to 300 sorties a day against
suspected communist positions many
innocent villagers were undoubtedly
killed or made homeless by the raids
the plane of jars in northern laos so
called because of its ancient megalithic
rock structures became the most
intensely bombed place on earth
in 1960 the plane of jars had a
population of 150 000 people by 1970
just 9 000 were left
of the 83 000 water buffalo in the
province
50 000 were killed by the bombings
to the peasants and tribes people of
laos the bombing campaign was like
something out of a nightmare one
villager said quote the planes came like
birds and the bombs fell like rain
soon northern and eastern laos looked
like the surface of the moon totally
barren pitch black
one u.s air force officer said quote
there just aren't any villages in
northern laos anymore
of the roughly ten thousand villages in
the country thirty five hundred were
held for the patatlao
of these the majority were obliterated
by bombing
[Music]
the girl employees say they are not
afraid of the enemy
they will willingly endure any hardship
no matter how long the fight goes on
there will be no happiness for anyone
until the united states is defeated
[Music]
it was not until the early 1970s that
people learned just how extensive the
american bombing of laos had been
the cia kept it such a close secret that
even leading senators were shocked to
find out that america had been bombing
for years
in the meantime an entire nation had
been bombed to the dust
but the surprising thing was that nobody
in america really cared
laos was not what got nixon in trouble
nobody in the military or the cia lost
their jobs
laos was an afterthought
and in 1975 after the bombing ended
the pathet lao managed to sweep to
victory
causing their rivals to flee to thailand
and america
[Music]
but the legacy of the bombing remained
powerful because 30 percent of the bombs
had never gone off so the landscape of
laos was still covered with unexploded
munitions which would detonate and kill
people when touched
in the decades since the bombing ended
thousands of lotions have been
permanently disfigured by bombs
there were so many bombs lying around
that some restaurants would use them as
decoration
schools put up warnings so that children
would know to avoid unexploded bombs
kids even earned money by dismantling
bomb scraps
since the 1970s about 20 000 lotions
have been killed by unexploded bombs
a massacre in slow motion
[Music]
about a quarter of villages in laos
still have unexploded munitions
40 of those killed were children
laos was once called the land of a
million elephants
now it's the land of a million
unexploded mobs
eight-year-old braun young has shrapnel
in his side he made the mistake of
playing with what he thought was a ball
instead it exploded
in 2016 the us government finally
admitted what it had done in laos
over the years thousands of laotians
have been killed or injured
farmers tending their fields
children playing and that's why as
president i've dramatically increased
our funding to help remove these
unexploded bombs
still what america did in laos remains
obscure
it's not taught in schools in america
it is totally forgotten
[Music]
and the destruction in laos did not
teach the american government any
lessons about how to treat other
countries in the future
our two governments
will continue to have differences that's
true with many nations
as we do around the world the united
states will continue to speak up on
behalf of what we consider universal
human rights including the rights
of the people allow us to express
yourselves freely and decide your own
future
in the 1960s and 70s laotians had wanted
to determine their own future among
themselves to determine what type of
country they would be
american bombing was designed to stop
that
and that pattern of force never really
stopped
in the decades after the american
strategy of overwhelming air power would
be used all over the world to intervene
in other countries
a strategy of shock and awe
and each time the worst consequences
would be born not by the fighters on any
side but by innocent people who did
nothing to deserve what came to them
[Music]
[Music]
you